there's a place called the pyramid
Tatara Khoikhoi yeah off the Chatham
Islands this one rock basically is the
only place in the world where this
exceptionally beautiful extremely rare
bird breeds the entire global population
of 5,000 something Pierce returns to
only this one place to nest Oh eggs in
one basket literally that risk the whole
range of things and one of the biggest
Fritz and the Chatham's here is yeah
impacts of climate change if you are
seeing mortality at a rate of say 10
percent a year than a decade or two
you're talking about an extinction the
risks were simply getting too high so
their goal was to create a new colony of
Chatham now the trusses on the main
island of the Chatham's and that sounds
easy but this is some of the most
impressive and incredible conservation
work I've ever had the privilege to
witness
there's only perhaps three or four days
a year where the sea conditions are good
enough for you to actually land on that
Island
they will vomit exorcist style on to any
person that tries to grab them but heat
is the number one danger
so once you put the first albatross
chicks in one of those boxes the clock
begins to tick so once the birds are off
the pyramid and they're on the boat the
journey really begins
they are landed at a river mouth that is
quite close to the new colony we bring
the checks here noon East every day with
weed we go down and feed them and give
them water whatever sound system that
plays calls we have D please put after
my marker colony you can't take the Trix
with her too young because they can't
survive without their parents but if you
take them at the right age and let them
complete their fledging process they
will leave but they will have imprinted
that location in their minds when it's
time for them to breed they will go back
to where they themselves fledged you let
this play out over a decade or two and
suddenly you have a new breeding colony
so we would not have seen even the first
years translated tricks returning yet
because they're still not quite old
enough to breed but that should be
happening any year now it's sort of just
waiting really for the birds to come
back these sea bird crisis is probably
one of the most pressing conservation
concerns of our time we've lost in the
region of 70% of the global zebra
population last 60 years you know
hundreds of thousands of arks and
Corman's die every year drowned in gill
nets our fisheries are literally taking
fish out of the sea birds beaks you know
we found introductions of invasive mice
and cats and rats that wreak havoc with
with with seabird eggs and with the
chicks
this is an enormous crisis that's going
on almost completely invisible to
everyone in the world because seabirds
are by their very nature not around
where we are the Chatham Islands and the
pyramid and this albatross for me are a
symbol of hope that even though you know
seabirds globally are in dire straits we
mustn't give up and there are ways to
turn things around
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you